rationnelle des produits car jamel
comedy club mais aussi d' indigènes
le film de rachid bouchareb avec roschdy
zem sami bouajila samy naceri vous
sortie le 27 septembre pour lequel vous
avez eu tous un prix d'interprétation
collective au dernier festival de cannes
alors
je fume on en parlera quand il sortira
on en parlera à la première de
t'approcher l'émission par exemple il a
réglé ouais
pourquoi prendre et celles qui aiment
tendrait et l'europe là cette mission
vous devez successivement dire du gain
de laurent gerra et du mal du mal de
zinedine zidane du mal et du bien
déranger un étudiant de zinédine zidane
et dire du bien de rentrer